et vous savez parfaitement de quoi on
parle
isabelle dose puisque vous êtes maman de
trois garçons
racontez-moi les prénoms et leur âge
martin 19 ans simon 15 ans et edward
sept ans comment avez vous su pour
martin simon et edward qu'il était à
haut potentiel surdoué ou précoces en
fait mon second a déclaré une phobie
scolaire en sixième est derrière cela
les professionnels nous orienter
effectivement vers cette possibilité
nous sommes allés voir un psychologue
puisque seuls les psychologues ou les
neuropsychologues peuvent faire passer
ces tests
et voilà un service d'ailleurs très très
puissant du côté de lyon 1
on est hors de la bourgogne france comté
mais c'est vrai qu'il faut c'est
d'olivier aux bonnes personnes voilà
c'est ça tout à fait alors pour ceux qui
sont avec nous et qui se posent cette
question est ce que mon enfant est à
haut potentiel et surdoué ou précoces
voici quelques éléments de réponse en
couleurs regardez maman papa je m'ennuie
à l'école vous entendez souvent cette
phrase
et bien dites vous que soit votre enfant
est malin et a compris que l'école et
vous ça faisait doux voire même plus
soit il est atypique
eh oui c'est comme ça que l'on appelle
les enfants à ou potentiels on dit
également enfants précoces ou même petit
zèbre
ça évite ainsi de coller une étiquette
pas toujours adapté à la personnalité de
l'enfant
oh mon enfant est donc surdoué tête ben
qu'oui ptêt ben qu'non
les enfants à haut potentiel ne le sont
pas tous mais alors qu'est ce qui change
et bien l'enfant précoce réfléchi ou agi
différemment de ses petits camarades
l'ennui à l'école est un symptôme fort
mais le manque de concentration mais
aussi il peut faire preuve d'une grande
lucidité sur des sujets comme la mort
d'un perfectionnisme qui frise
l'obsession avoir un sens de la justice
a serré et une hypersensibilité
difficile à gérer avec tout ça pas
facile de suivre l'enseignement
classique
d'ailleurs un enfant sur trois a ou
potentiels rencontrent des difficultés
dans sa scolarité et le qi dans tout ça
en france un enfant est communément
considéré comme précoce quand son qi est
égal ou supérieur à 130 sur cette base
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
estime ainsi à 2,3 pour cent notons
enfants intellectuellement précoces
scolarisés en france ce qui représente
quand même deux cent mille enfants ou de
son petit zèbre comme vous voulez alors
vous vous exposez décorateur 110 et
trois garçons trois enfants précoces
surdoué ou à haut potentiel qualité
votre premier réflexe vous vous avez
vous avez eu tous ces signes là qu'on a
fait c'est extrêmement représentatif de
ses enfants tout les réunit c'est à dire
pour par exemple les pronoms martin
puisque j'étais le premier à 19 ans
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui s'est passé à
quel moment vous l'avez détectée
je suis vraiment faim on la détecte et
quand il l'a fait un refus de l'école
voilà en troisième il est que vous
appeliez tout à l'heure une phobie
scolaire et non c'est encore autre chose
voilà lui a en 2e année de maternelle il
savait lire et écrire
ah oui voilà mais quand c'est son
premier enfant ben on suit ce normal
bon on se pose pas de question oui
qu'ils échapperont pas des chats donc
maman va bien papa va bien tout le monde
va bien bien qu effectivement pas de
soucis ensuite
à l'école l'instituteur lui fait passer
une classe mais ma foi écoles rurales
trois niveaux tout normal tout le monde
va bien donc voilà jusqu'au jour où ça
ne va plus bien effectivement et en
troisième refus de l'école insolence
violence ennuis mal être général et là
on se pose la question mais on peut se
dire quand même pardonnez moi oui je
t'en veux que vous alliez plus loin on
peut se dire bah c'est la crise
d'adolescence la même en dehors et on
était là dedans vraiment donc si mon
deuxième n'avait pas fait sa phobie
scolaire je pense qu'on serait passer à
côté du grand voilà on n'aurait pas su
que c'était aussi un fort potentiel
on savait juste comme on dit c'est il
fait une grosse crise d'adolescence
en fait donc vous avez eu quand même la
démarche alors c'est quoi c'est
l'enseignant c'est vous c'est en lisant
ces en vous informant quand ça s'est
passé comment vous avez détecté effet
d'un oui on alors l'objet les
informations en fait quand mon second a
fait sa phobie scolaire
je me suis renseigné pourquoi qu'est ce
que c'était une phobie scolaire de ça on
a découlé les informations effectivement
que ça pouvait être en lien parce que
c'est pas forcément français
évidemment ce n'est pas du tout et
ensuite les professionnels vous aiguille
aussi vraiment et vous conseille alors
concrètement quand vous dites les
professionnels vous aiguiller vous
conseille ça veut dire que vous faites
passer des tests on parle de kuyl dans
ce qu'on a vu c'est à dire le quotient
intellectuel il se retrouve avec un
professionnel il a des questions est
exactement ce sont des tests qui se
déroulent soit avec un psychologue soit
avec un neuropsychologue et si un test
qui dure quatre heures que le genre de
question il ya dans ce test tout c'est à
dire du français des maths de la lecture
de l'orthographe du ressenti c'est un
test vraiment extrêmement complet
conteste sur l'attention
combien le chiffre pour vos enfants le
chiffre pour le cui tas je ne sais pas
parce que je refuse de me baser sur un
chiffre on sait maintenant un en faut
peu au potentiel peut l'être même s'il a
pas 132 cuit mais ça après c'est
vraiment les spécialistes qui serait
mieux l'expliquer alors voilà c'est
toute la difficulté parce que c'est ça
aujourd'hui vous êtes dans une
association encore une fois il ya
peut-être des gens qui sont avec nous là
qui se disent mon fils ma fille mon
petit fils et filles et peut-être à haut
potentiel c'est simplement une crise
d'adolescence
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez et
comment vous les aider avec votre
association
en bourgogne franche comté alors
l'association dans le vin payant c'est
surtout un accueil téléphonique déjà
pour répondre un peu à tous ces parents
qui se questionnent oui est ce qu'ils
vous disent concrètement il décroche le
téléphone ils vous disent alors isabelle
mon gamin il fait n'importe quoi il est
peut-être surdoué
non il ya plusieurs questions en fait il
y en a qui me disent je vous appelle
parce que la maîtresse pense que mon
enfant voilà il ya quand même des choses
on dirait bien que oui et là du coup ben
effectivement la maîtresse leur dis ça
mais après qu'est ce que je fais donc
moi je leur conseille en leur disant que
de toute façon en france
seul ce test fait preuve de on n'a pas
le choix c'est comme ça donc c'est le
fameux test de qi voilà parle exactement
fait par des professionnels d'autres
parents m'appellent ils sont plutôt en
crise voilà et là il m'appelle au
secours
et quand on est en crise voilà j'essaie
de avec mes propres moyens et surtout
par rapport à mon vécu personnel de les
aider voilà se mettre en lien avec des
psychologues si besoin avec des
acupuncteurs avec des ostéopathes il ya
beaucoup de professionnels qui peuvent
aider ces enfants là l'équipe est
sensible à l'opéra qui sont exaltants
semble donc ça change mais ce qu'il faut
surtout savoir c'est qu'en fait ce sera
l'enfant qui choisira le professionnel
avec qui veut travailler ça c est les
parents le verrons le ressentiront vous
me parlez de crise isabel dos se traduit
par quoi c'est un gamin qui se renferme
ce contraire un gamin qui s'extériorise
c'est quoi il ya les deux effectivement
il ya des enfants qui sont très très
très introverti dans la lune même dans
leur monde sait ça complètement dans
leur bulle donc il y en a d'autres qui
sont plutôt dans l'hyper tout comme je
dirais donc l'hyper verbalisation l'ip
est resté zee
lippert anxiété l'hyperactivité voilà
j'ai souvent entendu dire je sais pas ce
que vous en pensez marie thérèse où vous
marion j'ai souvent entendu dire à
propos de ses enfants précoces surdoué
ou à haut potentiel c'est des enfants
qui posent 25 questions ils attendent
même pas forcément la réponse puis des
fois des trucs c'est ça on comprend pas
côté sa moins juste pour illustrer hier
soir mon petit à 21h voilà qui est 700
dormir parce que l'endormissement et
très compliqué pour ces enfants aussi
m'interpelle en disant maman c'est quoi
une voyante
d'accord ça c'est edouard donc c'est ça
c'est les douars
c'est donc c'est en voilà à 5 ans et est
maman
oui on meurt d'accord donc mon corps va
dans la terre sommes en terre parce que
je suis mort mais mon âme
elle va ou maman voilà donc faut
répondre que surtout répondre même si on
ne sait pas quoi leur dire je ne sais
pas te répondre
et ils disent ok mais on leur a répondu
ok mais vous allez peut-être répondre à
une question maintenant posée par
isabelle de chevigny saint sauveur
regarde
bonjour je m'appelle isabelle je suis de
chevigny saint sauveur et je
souhaiterais savoir s'il existe des
écoles pour les enfants
intellectuellement précoces et dans
quelle ville et à quel coût
merci alors on va pas faire le catalogue
de toutes les villes et forcément ça
semblait évident a le mieux c'est
d'aller faire un petit tour sur internet
mais néanmoins en bourgogne franche
comté je crois qu'il ya une école
quelque part non à ma connaissance il y
en a une à chalon sur saône alors ce
n'est pas une icône mais il ya des
classes e ip ils appellent ça enfants
intellectuellement précoces une des
écoles privées quant au coût je ne
saurais répondre
et sinon je conseille à cette dame
d'appeler l'éducation nationale est
peut-être l heure à des réponses elle
lui denis et puis rendez vous sur le
site de l'association pour une demande
d'un faucon plémentaires on va le mettre
sur votre écran
on va pas faire le catalogue encore une
fois mais c'est vrai que l'association
c'est l'afep l'association française
pour les enfants précoces et des liens
qui sont très bien faits beaucoup
d'informations on le voit d'ailleurs sur
sur l'écran là on vient de vous le
vous m le site internet de la fep vous
me disiez ce sont des enfants il perd
tout j'imagine que ceux qui sont avec
nous se disent moi un moment je peux
plus j'ai les bras qui tombent je sais
plus quoi faire
allez s'il y avait une seule chose à
faire qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire face à
ses enfants isabelle la priorité je
pense c'est que prendre soin de soi si
l'adulte va bien si l'adulte prend du
recul et si l'adulte est en phase avec
lui même alors ça va apaiser l'ambiance
familiale
allez vous rester avec nous et isabel
dos on va reparler de ces enfants qui
sont parfois fatigant forcément
intéressant mais souvent déroutant c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire